je dire qu'il est complètement faux sur
l'altercation qui a pu se passer en ou
raphaël aujourd'hui mois et angel s'est
complètement quand elle parlait du
harceleur pape alé lô ailleurs les des
nattes en émoi tout d'accord je vous
explique ça fait nous on n'a pas pris
une fois la parole sur les réseaux
sociaux
oui d'accord ni ma femme ni moins
d'accord ça fait dix quinze jours que
j'entends que j'aurais été violent que
j'aurais été que je l'aurait harcelée
d'accord je vais vous dire ça fait dix
ou quinze jours qu'on a pris un avocat
10 ou quatre jours que notre avocat nous
demande de se taire
on a demandé à la production par le
biais de notre avocat les images de 19h
à minuit de ce qui s'est passé lors de
cette soirée pour justement prouvé que
je suis pas en tort maintenant
malheureusement il ya un tribunal
aujourd'hui qui est médiatique sur la
syrie beaucoup plus rapide
je suis un tribunal beaucoup plus rock
ratisse voilà enfin mais on le verra au
niveau du procès qui va prendre plus de
temps
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on vient
ici parce que c'est un tribunal
médiatique mais vous verrez que
compagnie oui quand vous entendez ça
simon 10 / / / votre amoureux mais ça ça
vous pèse connaissez vous le
reconnaissez pas dans les descriptions
qu'on lui ont fait lui mais jamais de la
vie moi je vis avec ça fait deux ans et
demi qu'on est ensemble à aucun moment
c'est un homme violent quand je vois
angel ce qu'elle a fait sur les réseaux
sociaux moi je vais vous dire elle à
hapoël a amené l appeler à la haine
aujourd'hui je me suis menacé
aujourd'hui je suis une femme battue
vous rendez compte des propos je suis
une femme bacchus à me dire qu'il me bat
je reçois des messages tous les jours
des menaces de la haine c'est ce qu'elle
a fait les petits jeunes qui nous
soutiennent sur les réseaux qui ont des
comptes femmes se font menacé et harcelé
ils ont 12 13 ans et jean donc ça allait
beaucoup trop loin et elle a fait du
cimt du cyber harcèlement
elle parle d'harcèlement à l'époque
n'est plus un secret depuis dijon n'a
pas attendre c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas
parlé sur les réseaux sociaux
accor prend des coups mais après je suis
une histoire une petite halte d'accord
qui a été à la retraite
je suis quelqu'un qui bat sa femme j'ai
couché avec la directrice générale soit
disant de la production ça va beaucoup
trop loin ça me plaît je sens que vous
avez presque les larmes aux yeux quand
vous entendez presque parce que c'est
horrible séjourne à une famille
quand on a des parents des soeurs des
frères vous rendez compte comme le bar
vos parents vos mets mes parents ils
sont devant la télé je les embrasse des
rires mais c'est très difficile pour
nous pourquoi ils disent et on parle pas
de mon fils ça quand on dort mais mais
mais s'il vous plaît je veux en supplie
un moment donné soyez juste essayé moi
je voulais avoir bossé pas à vous que je
parle aux médias
s'il vous plaît essayez de voir plus
loin que le bout de votre nez arrêtez
les médias cesser les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui c'est en train de tuer le
monde
mais vous savez bien sûr et attention un
problème c'est la vérité ce que didier
pallages d'entretien non écoutez je vais
vous dire très sincèrement c'est un
engrenage
c'est la vérité il ya un mois je fais de
la télé je vais prendre mon argent et
j'ai envie de dire et je rentre chez moi
et ça s'arrête là j'oublie tout ce qui
s'est passé là-bas parce que pour moi je
vais prendre avec moi dans ma tombe
juste les souvenirs mais pas des leurs
est ce ça n'existe pas c'est éphémère
après les lattois je veux rentrer que
les souvenirs c'est tout je veux il faut
se mettre à jour été rappelés dans les
télés pourquoi parce que oui c'est un
fort caractère qui n'a pas la langue
dans sa poche ça oui c'est vrai c'est
pour ça qu'il a toujours été rappelé et
il dit parfois parce que tout haut ce
que les gens pensent tout bas je viens
aucun secouriste violent